let's see if we can figure out what 4
and 4/5 divided by 1 and 1/2 is and I
encourage you to pause the video and see
if you can figure it out on your own and
I'll give you a hint see if you can
rewrite these mixed numbers as as what
is sometimes called improper fractions
alright now let's do this together so
how can we rewrite 4 and 4/5 well 4 and
4/5 is the same thing as if we take the
4 that's the same thing as 4 plus 4 fish
4 plus 4/5 and 4 is the same thing as
twenty-fifths so 4 is the same thing as
twenty-fifths and then plus 4 this well
what are you going to get you're going
to get you add the numerators you get 20
4/5 24 fish another way to think about
it is take this denominator takes the
fifths multiplied by 4 you get twenty
fifths plus the 4/5 that you already
have is 24 fish and so this is the same
thing as 24 fifths divided by if you do
the same idea one and a half's the same
thing as 1 plus 1/2 1 is the same thing
as 2 halves plus 1/2 and so that's going
to be add the numerators that's going to
be 3 halves so just like this we're able
to rewrite our expression as 24 fifths
divided by three halves and now the key
realization is is that that is the same
thing as 24 fifths times the reciprocal
of 3 halves so times pause the video
what's the reciprocal of 3 halves well
the reciprocal of 3 halves you just swap
the numerator in the denominator it's
going to be 2 over 3 now what is this
going to be well there's a couple of
ways to do it you could just straight-up
multiply the numerators and you would
get 48 and then multiply the
denominators and you would get 15 so you
get 48 over 15 but you might be able to
rewrite that in slower and/or and more
sometimes what's called a more
simplified way but another way of
thinking about this is you could just
say well this is the same thing as 24
times 2 times 2
over five times three and simplify
things before you even multiply them out
five times five times three and you
realize that look 24 and 3 are both
divisible by 3 so let me divide them
both by 3 so 24 divided by 3 is 8 and 3
divided by 3 is equal to 1 and then you
could multiply the numerators and the
denominators and so and so you get in
the numerator 8 times 2 is 16 in the
denominator you get a 5 so you get 16
fifths and then if you want to express
that as a mixed number 16 over 5 well 5
goes into 16 three times with one left
over so this is 3 and one fifth and one
thing to appreciate right over here I
simplify then the 24 and the three of
this step sometimes you'll see people
simplifying at this step so they'll say
hey look eventually I'm going to have a
24 in the numerator and a 3 in the
denominator so let me divide both of
those by 3 so they'll say 24 divided by
3 is 8 and then a 3 divided by 3 is 1
and this is sometimes called a cross
reduction but this is all that's going
on right over here